[Music]
marcus mariota the second overall pick
in the 2015 draft is due to become a
free agent and
reportedly
the las vegas raiders are interested in
mariota now i don't know that mariota is
an upgrade over derek carr i don't know
what any of this would mean to derek
carr chris it could be that mariota
becomes the ryan tannehill to mariota
from a year ago where mariota just sits
and waits and watches and if derek carr
screws up enough john gruden puts him in
the game yeah the rest is history but
you know this one is odd to me
because you would think that the raiders
were so many quarterbacks out there this
year that they would be aiming high
maybe they're going to go that tannehill
route have a guy ready and use that guy
to push derek carr to maybe get to a
higher level just see how he deals with
the presence of somebody who could
supplant him if he struggles i think
that's what they're doing i do i mean
first off as you know i get to bring out
my favorite phrase i mean john gruden's
a quarterback hoarder that's what he
does i mean he's always looking to
upgrade that room make competition make
people uncomfortable that's what he's
going to do right and i think yes by by
the signals of hearing nate sutfeld a
little last week and now marcus mariota
okay that does tell me that yeah they're
planning on going with derek carr as
their starting quarterback but with a
guy like marcus mariota you're right
they're also telling me hey we like
derek carr we want to push him
but this guy's talented enough if derek
carr slips up in week five or six that
we can replace him with mario to do
something mariota certainly has
potential as we know he's got physical
ability now the one thing that why i
don't give him the ryan tannehill chance
over marcus mariota and say mariota
could do it to derek carr is i got to
see mariota's throwing go to another
level first that's what concerns me
about him you know tannehill the reason
i made those comments last year when the
titans first signed them is because i
knew tayden hill had the ability to be
really like a bullseye type thrower i'm
not so sure about that with marcus
mariota athletic gruden might have some
cool uh taste some hill type plays for
him i think that could be a part of it
but you know derek carr is still a
better thrower of the football than
marcus mariota and that's where i think
derek carr will be able to sleep easy at
night
hey chris here's one area where i think
it's going to be hard for marcus mariota
to fit with john gruden we've seen time
and again and you lived it yeah john
gruden wants his quarterbacks to have a
swagger he wants them to be loud he
wants him to be in your face he wants
them to take charge we've sat with
marcus mariota he's not that guy
and john gruden is not going to be able
to coax it out of him it's just not
there and that in and of itself makes me
wonder why gruden would want mariota
that's a it's a valid point mike you're
exactly right that you're exactly right
there i mean i question that as well and
you know maybe i i hope maybe john can
appreciate a guy maybe taking another
approach i mean marcus mariota does have
like that zen
calmness about him and we've seen
quarterbacks be like that and be
successful too so we'll see but you're
right the personality doesn't seem like
it's a mesh
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports